oh he is indeed their quarterback for
2019 and maybe for 2020 ralph faquiano
of sny
says that key people in the organization
think man manning still has something
left and there's an openness to
extending his contract into 2020 he's
only signed through 2019
vacano also says the owners have
complete faith in gm dave gettleman and
believe his vision believe in his vision
for rebuilding the franchise i i assume
he's shared with them the plan he won't
share with anyone else and frankly i
think he's just doing what he's told to
do and i think they are i think they are
just trapped in this vortex of keeping
eli manning for as long as he wants to
be there because they tried to bench him
and it blew up in their faces and now
they are going the other way and keeping
eli as long as he wants to stay and just
hoping that he chooses to leave before
it gets even uglier than it's been yeah
well i i just don't understand what the
thinking is here with this the whole
process i really don't you know again
eli manning's done a lot of great things
for the new york giants football team
and we know he's won two super bowls and
had two epic playoff runs where he was
so clutch but mike i mean since 2011
they've been to the playoff one they've
been to the playoffs one time okay 2016
where it wasn't exactly like eli blew
you know blew us all away with his play
the year they went to the playoffs in
2016. it was a lot of you know odell
beckham jr slants taking her to the
house it was the number one defense in
football his quarterback rating that
year was 86 it was some there in the
mid-20s as far as nfl starting
quarterback so to me it makes no sense
when you look at it on film and you look
at the play and i evaluate it as a
player evaluator and it makes no sense
just as a common fan with the optics on
the outside to go wait we've been to the
playoffs once since 2011
and we are going to continue to ride or
dive with this quarterback and make
excuses and and just constantly kind of
pedal or push this conversation for
drafting a quarterback or moving on
down the road and i don't understand it
mike i mean listen to the records i mean
it's 2013 it's seven and nine fourteen
is six and ten fifteen is six and ten
sixteen two thousand sixteen we talked
about it's playoffs eleven and five then
it was 2017 three and thirteen and then
last year five and eleven i don't know
another quarterback who could ever make
it through that alone uh unless i guess
you've won two super bowls
last week shireen williams was with me
for one of the radio segments on pft
live and we were in arizona and she's
got one of the votes for the hall of
fame and her thinking is that eli
manning is doing damage to his potential
enshrinement chances by playing as
poorly as he has late in his career now
in my view the hayes in the barn it
stays in the barn but
i don't have a vote she does and at what
point does eli have to be concerned that
his accomplishments are going to be
overshadowed by this extended stretch on
the back end of his career where he
isn't canton worthy chris yeah well i
know i mean you know again eli is one of
these where i would say this he's like
the uh the worst great quarterback ever
okay that's like kind of the phrase i
would use for eli like he's not in the
class of a brady or an aaron rodgers or
a drew brees or anybody like that he you
know he's on his own his own class of
two super bowl winning quarterbacks
towards the bottom of the totem pole
there really we're talking about a
quarterback who was two games above 500
for his career you know those things
like that they don't ring like oh man
slam dunk hall of famer right out the
bat there and if he doesn't have a good
year this year and the giants don't have
a good year he could be below 500 when
all said and done
would you rather be
the worst good quarterback or the best
bad quarterback uh i would rather be i
don't know that's a good question i
guess the i guess i'd rather be the
worst bat though the worst best
quarterback instead of the best worst
quarterback yes
because if you're the worst best
quarterback you at least have a super
bowl right exactly right hey somehow
you're on an impressive list you're just
on the bottom of it
more pfd live right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports